you guys also happen to be really good
at acting
it's hard to say you say plural guys are
[Laughter]
you thinking he always says i'm bad okay
i have never i'm not you always say i'm
bad and it hurts my feelings you're li
and you're lying for the joke of the
show but i've never seen it what did i
say
about reservation dogs what did i really
say you said i was good on that very
good dude he's very good on the show not
the same very used a couple minutes ago
the same very easy
[Laughter]
do you think that he's better than you
at acting just just being it wow
there's a competition there too no no no
no we're just saying objectively
because when it comes to improv you guys
are magic like
i was sitting there on your guy's show
[ __ ] crying when i did bad friends
the last time when you guys did the
scene where the [ __ ] girl gets pulled
though
it was amazing okay now
but when you're talking about just
acting like let's say you had to do a
scene let me ask you a question and it's
you or santino do you don't think that
santino just has another gear bro like
let me ask you another question all
right yeah
yeah we're not talking about comedy
we're not talking about stuff i know get
what you're talking about
i get what you're [ __ ] saying and you
would know you guys went for similar
roles in the past we went for similar
roles he got everyone in work
and we're actually asking because i
haven't seen any of your shows so whoa
again with a dagger bro
dude
oh
you can't see my dick
did you see what he just did
did you see that i thought
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but here's here's the thing may i ask
you a question that's all i'm gonna ask
you a question right yeah do you think
he has had more opportunities over the
years
you think because he is do you think
he's had more opportunities over the
years and i'm going to be and that's an
honest question
i think the answer to that is yes i
think that you've been alive so much
longer
[Laughter]
like when you were acting in those
movies that just had the writing on it
instead of the words like
you know
when you had that crotching tiger
jesus right this guy redoing it
yeah yeah
yeah okay all i'm saying is i've
obviously had not had more opportunity
that's [ __ ]
oh that's so [ __ ] crazy you got a mad
tv like five years into the game you
were literally on a [ __ ] hit
television show hit five years into the
game yeah that's true you barely were
you barely were in the world of comedy
and action everything you were weak you
did miss swan or whatever that wasn't me
wait what that was alex sports june oh
yeah
uh oh hot dog that wasn't louis that was
me that was you that was oh i thought
that was good
not as popular but that was okay so that
was so much that was so much opportunity
yeah this poor guy barely has a single
opportunity crushes it every single time
climbs out of the [ __ ]
dirt
okay let me ask you a question then dude
and be all completely honest yeah yeah
how many auditions do you get a year
whoa
i don't have to anymore i know but
balkan when you did
yeah man
no no i'm kidding of course back when
you did of course i still auditioned
back in the day though how many did you
get a year
be completely honest uh honestly yeah
probably a couple i don't know a couple
a few no how many years i can't really i
don't really know 30. here's the let's
let's
let me ask you a question
let's let's go
[Laughter]
you're pretending as if i was this
handsome picked dude the redheaded guy
is never tell me the [ __ ] love story
where they go just got cut off tell me
the love story where they go oh
beautiful
her
red-headed husband walks in never was i
like the hot boyfriend who no dude i had
to go out for [ __ ] that was like you
would just get that roll every time
we are both good at our things yeah
nobody is better at his thing than him
what is his thing uh
uh want me to do the [ __ ] on the hands
he's a jordan a place where they're like
yeah that's a [ __ ] oh my god that's his
[ __ ] another one have another one
nobody's better at their thing than at
his thing than him that's what i just
there it's it's undisputed yes there's
only one bobby leaf straight that's what
i mean
and i could i could have to go head to
head with
some you know what i mean a bunch of
frond for a role no chance i think i
think the only time that i would have
like uh you know who i was jealous you
know i feel like i could be the uh the
who'd you beat out i wanna know who you
beat out on somebody i don't know
i don't know but how do you know no but
i can tell you i can tell you that miles
teller kid i i like him so much
and i'm jealous
though about your dad huh could you be
emotional about could you be was the
name rooster rooster could you do that
you gotta be all emotional about goose
there's no way and angry at tom cruise
can you cry you can do drama
can you cry hold on you've been crying
the scene yeah you can cry right now
yeah this is i feel like bobby's not set
up for it
i'll do it i'll i'll set up a scenario
yeah let's go all right okay [ __ ] in
your face all right
every scenario right yeah okay all right
so i'm like let's a movie it's like
philadelphia yeah but i'm you know being
a little nigerian kid yeah this is a
comedy yeah no no no and i'm adopted i'm
i have ebola instead of aids that's not
the stakes aren't high enough for this
yeah
we need high stakes all right
able is not high
no i think you survive the ebola
if you're liquor fights you're older and
you're dead immediately that's not true
okay give me the stakes then okay
this is just we're throwing a
hypothetical thing out yeah
okay um
you're tasked with a mission to go
behind enemy lines
[Music]
um
with your old partner's son
what
your partner's son yeah
what he's tom cruise i think it's
similar but
[Laughter]
um okay
okay all right there's
there's the same
sports agent
and i quit and i want to go solo okay
all right but i want to be never heard i
want to be in the scene
huh you have to cry because i'm dying
how can we do that no wait if i what if
i what if i want to act too though well
what if i rap
what if i also rep like mahjong players
or stuff like that okay i don't know
yeah
the problem the problem is
me and him in any movie we'd ever do it
it's not impossible to try it'd be
laughter the whole thing okay okay so i
really want to get to a serious crack
okay okay so you're gonna come in right
at a later point in the scene all right
okay but is he gonna cry because of me
yes okay good thank you okay okay here's
a good one here's a good one no no
it's so hard
it's impossible you've got this you can
do it with you no you don't have that
listen bobby lock in you can make it
this is this is korean war
you were over there what a time what a
time
you you found out you fell in love with
a woman there who literally saved your
life behind enemy lines a white woman no
an asian woman behind enemy line no
can't do it i just don't buy it yeah
she's happy aside oh i buy it yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay i got it she's like piano
rings with tits
right like you know you don't know it
could be [ __ ] you know i mean eastern
european by the way
yeah not asian at all but yeah for sure
absolutely not asian natives
yeah like 10 asians yeah korean huh i
think new york is 10 korean yeah
she's trying to see iceland already can
we finish this yeah she's nordic she's
nordic can we say that which is mostly
asian okay okay how about this whoa dude
relax your sense
okay harvey weinstein's the producer
yeah
exact people
man budget
get in the hotel room and take your
clothes off
what
yeah there's an asteroid hurtling
towards earth and you and your friends
who are also oil drillers mostly in the
most difficult parts of the world okay
have to go up yeah and you have to do it
you do
you have to just split it in half with
an atom bomb
what yeah it's it's it's
either deep impact or armageddon make
your choice the point is
maybe that those are similar we're
secret agents yeah yeah yeah yeah and we
have the ability we're sent from the
government there's aliens walking
amongst us we have the ability to make
people forget what they've seen
okay
somewhere we're listing our favorite
movies
yeah
okay okay okay i will make up an actual
movie can you make up an original movie
original movie right right never been
done before i love it here it is here it
is all right are you ready i'm ready
there's two girls one cup
okay
what's in the cup
no no let's let's think of an accident
let's have santino cry come on what it
would be it would be so hard yeah
bobby's in a hospital yeah he got in a
car accident okay yeah so now i'm
playing myself and he's playing himself
right that's good he has five minutes to
live okay no no no no no you have you
notice how quick he went to you in a car
accident
earlier that was a
might as well trample more
all right
okay what a funny seat in the movie
transformers it goes back into a car and
crashes immediately everybody else
zooms away he hits a pole
all right so all right i'm in the
hospital yeah okay
that's your
that's your son okay needs a heart
transplant there's no donor
i got i'm just i'm so good
you take the the hospital hostage and
you realize there's only one heart
that can go in
your son's chest it's your own
you're gonna have to kill yourself to
save your son
he's getting there
very good all right you love that kid
more than anything in the world he was
dealt a bad deck probably from your
wife's side
you don't talk to her anymore so can we
do the scene and start soon
my son
i love you so much
and i got to tell you
the only heart that you can have is mine
but i'm not going to give it to you
what the [ __ ]
because there's so many other koreans i
can buy
goodbye
[Laughter]
ring bro that [ __ ] impressed me dude
choice that was really good that movie
get out get uh
get it play a dog play a dog
raise the roof oh man you're gonna
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to cut this
go go but get him to the shoulder
it's so you got it
give me that
one
yeah go ahead get him do the
funny
[Laughter]
because the second that's the middle of
the movie this happens the second half i
haunt him oh he haunts me because i let
him die you let him die
he gets a new song right but in the
house i
[Laughter]
like literally sold and sometimes i'll
go pan face
i'll do some adjectives you know
can you imagine when the ghost hunters
come to the house can we see this and
i'm like did you hear that did you hear
that on the on the thing and if they're
replaying it they're like i don't know
what he's saying
i think we all heard what he said yeah
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] we if by the way if we
we want to do a movie together me and
the bob bad bad bad yeah and we're
trying we just got we want you guys not
i just want like a really really like
acclaimed writer to write us i think
he's written a bunch of great scripts
just now
yeah one of those [ __ ] writers to
actually like write us a thing that's so
out of our
you know before normal rounds what's
funny is is if they wrote an actual
serious drama and you guys are not
serious it would be like oh i'm trying
to i don't think this is rocky horror
picture show but like what is that it
almost comes across as like camp like
you guys are trying to oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah everybody watching is
you're right yeah yeah hot american
summer i guess it's invisible it's like
a musical